[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui est-ce
Banzai Daniel Larusso ici pour Larusso
Auto nous réduisons les prix sur tout
notre inventaire ouais
Jonny je savais que c'était toi c'est
Johnny Lawrence lui et moi il y a
longtemps oh c'est un gars qui est une elle Kate  si
tu veux être technique, je lui ai donné un coup de pied au
visage, hé, regarde ta voiture, mec
[Applaudissements],
j'aime le taekwondo pour quelque chose
qui est du karaté, penses-tu que tu pourrais
m'apprendre, je rentre du
travail en voiture hier et
dans ce centre commercial
je vois après 30 heures  des années, je pensais que ce type
avait peut-être changé, que c'était toujours la
même impression,
je t'ai entendu tabasser un groupe d'adolescents,
ils n'ont battu aucun adolescent, j'ai
botté la merde à une bande de
connards qui le méritaient, ils pensent qu'il pourrait
amener Cobra Kai.  retour dans la vallée ouais
pas sous ma surveillance
tu sais ce que ces enfants à l'école -
continue de te jeter des choses sur la tête tu possèdes
toutes les filles pour penser que tu es une
porte sans Wang tu fais ce
professeur de karaté non je vais l'être  ton sensei
[Applaudissements]
Je vais t'apprendre le style de karaté
qui m'a été enseigné, une méthode pour
combattre ta génération de pensées a
désespérément besoin, ok, voyons ce que
tu as,
c'est une fille et je suis désolé, tu vas bien,
j'étais  un Cobra naturel
[Musique]
te carillonne et nous avons fini de me manquer